en efectivamente lo que pasa es que nos
encontramos una situación que tiene unas
consecuencias en estamentos
imprevisibles es decir las consecuencias
inmediatas a las cuales mencionabas era
el sufrimiento a la población como
víctima de bombardeos por ejemplo en
está por ver la dimensión que puede
tener la visión en estos momentos en lo
que está claro es que está habiendo
bombardeos en el conjunto del territorio
ucraniano no se limita específicamente a
la región de antofagasta la cual putin
había apoyado más explícitamente sino
que es una agresión al conjunto del país
y eso puede llevar una escalada a una
confrontación directa entre ejércitos
como no se ha visto en territorio
europeo
prácticamente desde la segunda guerra
mundial con lo cual hasta hasta la fecha
la noticia que tenemos ahora son son
casi que en muy muy muy limitadas las
afectaciones pero en muy pocos días esto
puede escalar hasta afectar a millones
de personas no solamente en ucrania sino
en el conjunto también de los países de
los países vecinos porque va a escalar
también también cristian hablemos de los
discursos de todos los protagonistas
principales uno de los protagonistas de
todo este conflicto de todas estas
tensiones que estamos viendo hablamos
del presidente ruso vladimir putin
hablamos del presidente de clear de
ucrania volodymyr selenski y hablamos
también de el discurso y la postura del
presidente de eeuu joe biden
vemos a un presidente putin muy decidido
muy seguro muy serio en lo que está
haciendo con una ruta con un plan de
acción vemos un presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski que en cambio pues
espera mucho de occidente se ve se ha
visto según también ha dicho pues
analistas un poco débil como apelando ya
también al corazón digamos que esto
puede jugar en su contra
mirándolo de los o como lo pueden ver
los rusos en este en este conflicto y
también un presidente joe biden que para
muchos también ha sido un poco tibio que
no ha tenido como bien clara marcada la
hoja de ruta que está pasando analicemos
esos esos tres discursos para ver
entonces cómo se pudieran desarrollar
estos hechos porque parece que por ahora
pues el que tiene todo ganado y el que
tiene todo más claro es el presidente
ruso vladimir putin
en cuanto al análisis del discurso lo
que ha sido terriblemente frustrante
estas últimas semanas es que los
discursos sobre todo los de los de rusia
los de putin y los de baden nos estaban
anunciando el desenlace que estamos
teniendo en estos momentos que era la
guerra y yo creo que es importante
resaltar que tanto desde ucrania pero
también desde el ámbito de la unión
europea y de otros espacios
internacionales como la organización
para la seguridad de la cooperación
europea y las naciones unidas había un
esfuerzo impresionante por la vía
diplomática para que lo que parecía
inevitable no lo fuera sino que
prevaleciera la prevención del conflicto
que no tuviéramos que llegar a la
situación actual
yo creo que ha cogido a muchos por
sorpresa que finalmente putin haya
decidido a lanzar un ataque porque a
partir de la acción de hoy es el agresor
y eso no cabe duda ante nadie y con esta
actuación
pues la mina completamente hecha por los
aires toda
iniciativa diplomática que haya habido
en estos últimos años y que puede ver
también en el futuro porque se ha roto
completamente la confianza en su propia
palabra mientras hablaba en buenos
términos con diplomáticos europeos
también con país y otros estaba
preparando esta este ataque y por lo
tanto cámbiate en tendrá un impacto no
solamente en la arquitectura de
seguridad europea sino en las relaciones
internacionales a escala a escala global
nos centramos ahora en un territorio
completamente desconocido donde
lastimosamente las reglas que nos hemos
marcado como comunidad internacional y
como humanidad de prevalecer la parte la
solución pacífica conflictos entre la
guerra pues entran completamente en
cuestionamiento